voi giorni siamo tutti quanti sono in
belgio per il tomorrow when questa è la
stanza che mandato non fate caso ai
calci e mi sono svegliato dal tipo 3 o 4
minuti
questo non è un 4 mai 12 questa è la mia
stanza e adesso vi spiego perché ridotta
così a merda non è come pensate ma la
reyer odio se c'è gente che sta fa il
picnic posso zoomare sulla gente che fa
il picnic stava montando il video di
oggi
e siccome sono qua in belgio per il
tomorrow land non è un gameplay ma ho
voluto approfittarne per montare
un'altra puntata di social face visto
che non posso fare gameplay visto che
c'è la ruota che mi fissa e oggi volevo
farvi vedere due delle mie sfide
preferite che ho fatto quando ho
registrato social face tanto siamo
finiti accesso vi faccio vedere questa
prima sfida di oggi che praticamente ho
sfidato bekas al ping pong
si chiama beer pong challenge quella
dove deve centrare i bicchieri con la
pallina da ping pong e poi berti
contenuto che non era birra magari e
niente vi lascio questa prima challenge
ci vediamo poi dopo io intanto magari la
finisca di fare avanti e indietro e
vorrei che voi avete a disposizione
delle palline dove le centrali il
bicchiere dell'avversario e nel caso tu
riesca a centrare il bicchiere o farei
un punto due tra bazar e dovrà
assaggiare il contenuto del bicchiere
vince chi riesce a fare più centri con
le palline che a disposizione
questa è la particola meno 10
ma cosa stai molleggiato ma così finisce
al sicuro attenzione a rimbalzo
[Musica]
non solo nella sua casa
senti ppd papa
[Musica]
questo è
questo test è ancora si è buono
[Musica]
giuseppe mantella nera notte vi propongo
una cosa hai a disposizione il tiro
della vita questa è proprio la vita che
ok mezzo donna nel caso tu riesca a
centrare uno d'acqua un punto per dire
questo
ok me la devo rischiare il proprio
scelto tre a zero a me
[Applauso]
il 50 di far indietro
e questa ragazza era la prima challenge
di oggi passiamo alla seconda che non è
che faccia meno schifo veramente
piuttosto preferisco andare a farmi un
giro a nudo sulla ruota panoramica prova
beh vi lascia la challenge bali allora
siamo nella bible challenge sasha e
lorenzo contro massimo e abbiamo due
cibi loro potranno indovinare questo
cibo con il tatto che prenderanno tre
punti con l'olfatto prenderanno due
punti con la degustazione prenderanno
posto con la vita 0
la gente li mettiamo una bella bolletta
così nel momento in cui scopriamo il
cibo loro nonna
sì però restano l'odore già letto nero
lettina bella chiuda quanti più loro ok
scopriamo il primo cibo
[Musica]
era uscito è un filetto un filetto no
bene bella è che quei punti persi anni
ama l'olfatto
[Musica]
ancora non so proprio quale non lo so
perché se va via a destra prima buca
ti prego ti prego non lo faccio più a
rischio vero che non lo voglio fare
che schifo mezzo punto si avviano la
morte
[Musica]
maiale che ne so no belle cose belle
cos'è è un fegato sta cosa passiamo a
sasha facendo natale è una patata non è
una patata così secondo me una
barbabietola ma come barba allo ragazzi
la seconda manche tocca a voi siete
pronti signor capito iniziano con simone
col ditino aspetta col ditino come ha
fatto giuseppe prima non ci deve essere
un agonia
descrive cosa senti senti un giorno male
perché io penso a fare già da
dall'assaggio elevate l'antichissima non
ci riesco la band ha intavolato un
conseguente cose via mastai scoprendo ci
andiamo a scartare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bravo alla sfida e quindi ragazzi
quest'anno le due challenge le tue
challenge di social face
io sono vestito molto bene e cosa dica
che assiste video è piaciuto il suo
documento è un mi piace anche a faccia
di facebook e condivido tutte nella
descrizione sotto l'ascella
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci mettiamo nel prossimo video bella
renzi si vede